this video is brought to you by ground
news what's up wisecrack socially
distance Jared here now if you're
watching this chances are your life has
recently been turned upside down by the
novel coronavirus kovat 19 is currently
causing mayhem all over the globe while
biologists sociologists all of the
ologists really are going to have plenty
to say about this whole thing in the
coming years it's impossible to predict
the full extent of the virus's impact
all we really know is that the world
will most likely look different when
this all shakes out that's because every
epidemic or pandemic in history from the
Black Plague to tuberculosis to HIV has
left a sizable mark on humanity
obviously there's the tragic death toll
but diseases have also altered shaped
and reshaped the course of social and
political history sometimes the
connections are very literal typhoid is
speculated to have knocked out Alexander
the Great the bubonic plague seems to a
fast track the downfall of the Byzantine
Empire and measles or smallpox likely
did the same to the Roman Empire but
diseases have also kick-started
everything from sexist morality laws to
public health infrastructure to rigorous
government surveillance so much so that
it's not a stretch to say that diseases
created the modern state as we know it
don't believe us we've got nothing but
time to prove it so join us on this
journey through the nasty microorganisms
that have changed human history in this
wisecrack edition on how the plague
created the modern world but first a
quick shout-out to our sponsor ground
news not unlike diseases the new cycle
has definitely shaped the modern world
misinformation and hysteria can be as
deadly in a pandemic as the disease
itself and it's important to check the
facts Health Authority guidelines and
vetted information before you decide to
loot stores for toilet paper between
newspapers cable coverage and social
media it's become harder and harder to
make your own judgment on news stories
these days luckily today's sponsor
ground news allows you to audit the
stories you read online so you can make
an informed opinion the app allows you
to view who has covered the same story
and where they fall on the political
spectrum you can make your own judgment
with less of a fear of being biased
ground news allows you to follow threads
and keep track of all the coverage so
you always know what is going on the app
is available on iOS or Android and is
free to download
it's a great tool to help you interpret
your news so download it now by clicking
the link in the description and now back
to the show today we're going to focus
on the bubonic plague because of the
unique way it shaped the modern world
now don't let the fun name fool you
bubonic plague is a horrific ly lethal
disease that mostly spreads by a fleas
who hang out on rats until they get the
chance to jump on to humans and chow
down the plague has swept various
countries and even entire continents
throughout history from ancient
Byzantium to mid 19th century India to
21st century Madagascar but we're gonna
focus on the second plague pandemic
known as the Black Death which began in
the mid 14th century like your dramatic
roommates troubled relationship it was
on again off again for approximately
five hundred years except it also killed
up to 50 percent of Europeans and didn't
end in makeup sex on your shared couch
naturally the plague generated terror
panic massive violence and a surge in
religiosity people desperately fled
infected cities under the prevailing
wisdom of the time which held that
plague and other maladies were caused by
miasma or the diseased air and all the
gnarly smells that haunted city life
societies were unprepared and physicians
were powerless in the face of an ugly as
hell disease often becoming sick
themselves the era's increased
urbanization meant more people lived in
closer often unhygenic quarters which
made it all the easier for fleas to jump
from rats to humans to spread the
disease also increased international
trade led to many rat infested boats
transporting spices textiles and of
course bubonic plague from country to
country economies were decimated social
order overthrown the works take Naples
which had nearly half its population
wiped out by the plague of 1656 as
scholar Frank Snowden writes in his book
epidemics and society every activity of
normal life ceased amidst shuttered
shops unemployment and hunger Snowden
depressingly notes that after a while
too few people were left alive to bury
all the dead throughout Europe suspected
sinners typically Jews and other
religious dissenters foreigners accused
witches and sex workers were banished or
even murdered by very scared very dumb
vigilantes reeling governmental systems
knew they
had to act fast thus began what Snowden
calls the first form of
institutionalized public health in 15th
century northern Italian city-states
that meant drafting plague regulations
which anointed new health magistrates
who were provided with full legislative
judicial and executive powers in all
matters related to public health by the
16th century in some cities these
initially temporary posts had grown into
permanent agencies that is boards of
health these efforts would according to
Snowden mark a vast extension of state
power into Spears of human life that had
never been subject to political
authority such extensions ranged from
the regulation of butcher meat to the
forced quarantine of entire populations
in Venice the office of Health created
to lazarettos or not very mellow islands
where ships coming from the eastern
Mediterranean were brought to be
disembarked and fumigated again because
they thought disease was spread through
bad smelling air hundreds of less than
stoked passengers were then isolated and
guarded for forty days which would
become known as a quarantine after the
Italian word for forty this number
incidentally was chosen because in
Christian scripture forty is associated
with purification Moses was on Mount
Sinai for 40 days before receiving the
Ten Commandments Christ was tempted for
forty days Christ ate with his disciples
for forty days after his resurrection
etc so basically super solid science
stuff as dumb as this was it also
happened to work because the incubation
period of bubonic plague was shorter
than 40 days once the practice was found
to be apparently effective in quelling
the spread in Venice other European
ports followed suit of course there was
still the threat of plague being spread
by travelers on land which vigilante
groups tried to stem by violently
patrolling city walls
this practice eventually became
regulated with troops being deployed to
form sanitary cordons ie military
barriers that stopped goods and people
from entering and forced them into
adorable 40-day timeouts one coordinate
in Austria was a thousand miles long
required mandatory service of basically
all male peasants and lasted a hundred
and sixty-one years as scholar Mitchell
Hammond summarizes in his book epidemics
in the modern world these kinds of
actions became integral to the modern
notion of a functioning state that
assumed responsibility for the
protection of borders and the
preservation of health among its
citizens haven't even argues that
concerns about plague began to override
concerns about independence among
Italian city-states
leading to widespread cooperative
efforts to stem the disease but of
course it wasn't just enough to keep
people out there was also the threat of
plague spreading within a city which is
where things get fascinatingly bleak
sanitary authorities took draconian
measures to prevent the disease from
spreading
they hired tons of municipal officials
to locate plague victims transport them
to lazarettos and bring corpses to
plague burial grounds this was an
intense process picture often drunk
searchers and body clears barging into
ship you're seriously ill roommate off
to some random island plus in Venice
around two-thirds of Lazaretto patients
died so this was for all intents and
purposes a likely death sentence and if
you did survive you'd be charged for the
stay a litany of other rules dotted
various cities including forcing pet
owners to kill their beloved fluffy
friends who were seen as potential
sources of disease which is the single
saddest fact I have ever learned other
restrictions ranged from forbidding
folks from selling clothes to banning
all public gatherings sometimes
isolation methods were taken where in
the house of a sick person was marked
with a red cross and in England wrote
the phrase lord have mercy upon us then
the sick person and their entire
household were forced into confinement
without any option for medical care and
left to die so salient is the example of
plague towns birthing modern power
structures that philosopher Michel
Foucault called a town under plague an
exceptional disciplinary model in other
words it was like a laboratory for the
government's exercise of social control
citing 17th century French archives
Foucault details the way local
governments separated each plague
written town into districts and those
districts into quarters and those
quarters into roads in a new process of
segmenting public space then there is
the literal organization and segmenting
of people every person in town was
required to register themselves in
centralized rec
then they had to go get provisions and
head into lockup
which meant basically never leaving the
house not even to walk your dog
long before CCTV or the NSA Foucault
argues that it was here that government
surveillance was born in each town a
road supervisor called a syndicate the
keys to every house on his block and
locked the door from the outside like a
prison guard syndics would make daily
roll calls at each house they'd call out
the name of each inhabitant who
one-by-one went to the window to
describe their current health condition
it was best to be frank because lying
about your fever could get you the death
penalty at least chill of all breaking
quarantine was and I can't stress this
enough punishable by death
huko notes that under these
extraordinary circumstances inspection
functions ceaselessly the gaze is alert
everywhere stuck within the four walls
of your probably shaky 17th century home
every move you made was subject to
supervision a tactic that was entirely
unfamiliar privacy vanished under these
conditions as every status update about
your health
went into the town's permanent records
as Foucault notes the plague is met by
order its function is to sort out every
possible confusion in the process such
extreme measures make each individual
subject to an omnipresent and omniscient
power thus according to Foucault public
health efforts ultimately were born and
sustained as a means of controlling
urban space and the environment and
expanded political power drastically
Foucault notes that some of the
practices employed in plague towns could
be related to the way people with
leprosy were treated when they were
banished to leper colonies the big
difference though is rather than
persecuting a select unfortunate few
fighting the bubonic plague met
segmenting all of society which arguably
resulted in a much more significant
proliferation of power creating what
Foucault called the utopia of the
perfect city with perfect here meaning
perfectly controlled following these
sorts of efforts by the 18th century
plague did essentially disappear from
Europe so draconian laws worked right
well maybe Snowden notes that these
policies were probably only one aspect
of what stopped the disease with other
aspects including changes in climate
hygiene and hypothetically genetic
however because these laws were
typically heralded as the chief cause of
Europe's salvation they have been
frequently replicated their apparent
success has in more recent pandemics
resulted in government's behaving
objectively by forcibly detaining people
surveilling them and otherwise
extinguishing their civil liberties and
no we don't mean just by closing all the
AI hops during the third plague wave at
the end of the 19th century colonial
Britain attempted to enforce such
measures in plague written Bombay with a
draconian zeal that it ignored local
religious cultural and medicinal
practices they divided sick people from
their families and burned infected
houses to the ground in what Snowden
calls public health by eviction and
destruction so brutal was the effort
that it caused half the population to
flee
thus paradoxically spreading the disease
further because again travelling flees
around the same time over in the States
Chinese Americans were also ordered into
quarantine with harsh laws that the
courts eventually overturned so plagues
cause intense laws that when carried out
badly can seriously infringe on life and
liberty what are we supposed to make of
the fact that now many of us are in
complete lockdown first off just so
we're clear stay the F home no one is
burning down houses yet in which case
we'd probably complain in times like
these it's also worth considering the
fact that the plague didn't simply
consolidate government powers and enable
abuse they've also caused some pretty
positive changes in society such as
contributing to the lower-class
uprising in England that eventually
ended feudalism to fostering a
nationalist sentiment in India that
would eventually lead to the country's
independence from colonial control
what's more the plagues role in
strengthening the modern state isn't all
bad either because that state gives you
drinkable water paved roads and it's a
pretty big player in the whole not dying
of smallpox thing all that said it's
hard to know what the effect of kovat 19
will be while bubonic plague is kind of
a Woodstock of infectious diseases other
epidemics have also catalyzed their fair
share of social change
syphilis once known as the pox created
huge stigmas around sex work and laws to
ban it smallpox introduced by Europeans
obliterated indigenous populations in
the Americas boarding any successful
resistance to colonization as
mattering of diseases like cholera and
typhoid created public health concerns
that led to widespread adaptation of
indoor plumbing in urban areas and
weirdly enough tuberculosis which spread
by coughs provoked fears over Hygiene
leading some to speculate that
tubercular bacteria could hang out in a
dudes beard or mustache as a result
facial hair tragically disappeared from
turn-of-the-century America for a time
at least what's ultimately so
fascinating and also scary about
diseases is the unintended ways they
change our perceptions of society health
and even our bodies while we're plenty
grateful for government-run indoor
plumbing it's still pretty weird to
realize that much of the way the state
gets involved in our day-to-day lives
stems from the terror and desperation
caused by infectious diseases but what
do you think wisecrack can we blame
bubonic plague for all our issues with
authority what legacy should we expect
kovat nineteen to leave in its wake and
above all when will I be allowed to
leave the house again let us know what
you think in the comments stay safe
healthy and sane and before you go I
want to give one last shout out to
ground news for sponsoring this video
ground news is the first news comparison
platform that allows you to see where
your news comes from you can track
stories and coverage to stay up to date
with everything going on in the world
it's a great tool to help you interpret
your news and read coverage across the
political spectrum the app is available
on iOS and Android and free to download
so check it out today thanks to all our
patrons for supporting the channel and
our podcasts don't forget to subscribe
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]